One of the biggest films this summer
is the new Planet of the Apes movie,
"War for the Planet of the Apes."
(applause)
I like that movie, now.
And people are saying the apes in it look so realistic
you immediately forget that they're all computer generated.
Well, guess what, this is kinda cool
I hired the people responsible for that technology
and as a special treat you are about to experience
some of that incredible CGI magic
right here in this theater.
Is this cool or what?
(applause)
Yeah!
Ladies and gentlemen of Comic-Con,
get ready to be invaded by the Planet of the Apes!
(applause)
(growling)
Humans,
bow down to apes.
No, no, no, wait a minute
wait a minute, stop.
Stop!
No, no one bow down.
What's going on here?
I thought we were going to see realistic, CGI apes?
Not a bunch of out of shape actors in green pajamas.
What's going on?
These not pajamas,
these state-of-art motion capture suits.
20 grand each.
Human need use imagination.
No, no, I can use my imagination.
I paid a lot of money for this and it looks incredibly lame.
I mean, look at that guy.
Look at that guy right there.
(laughter)
(applause)
And you!
You, what the hell is your name?
My name Socate!
(growling)
No, no, no, forget that shit.
What's your real name?
Randy Schwab.
(laughter)
It's an honor to meet you.
Big fan, big fan.
Okay, Randy what's happening here?
Okay, I'm a silver-back gorilla.
About seven-feet tall, big scar right down my face,
and this is my ape army.
Hey man, how's it going? Nice to meet you.
(applause)
Real honor.
Oh, and those guys are riding a CGI horse.
Okay, I thought that was a giraffe.
No, come on man, it's a horse.
It's gonna be badass, we just need a little more time.
Okay, how much time do you need?
Like five, six months max.
No, no, six months that's ridiculous.
(grunting)
Must protect babies from humans.
No, no, no.
Forget it Jessie, he's not buying it.
Aw man.
(laughter)
(applause)
Look,
thanks for giving it a shot,
but why don't you guys just go home, okay?
No, but we had this really big ender
where we put you in a massive cage.
You put me in a big cage?
Yeah, you'll love it. Okay guys, ape up.
(growling)
Human cannot visit us, lower the cage!
(suspenseful music)
(applause)
No, no this is really stupid.
I'm sorry.
Use your imagination!
No, I'm not going to use my imagination.
I'm not going to do that.
Human has escaped!
(screeching)